what's going on guys this is rob and uh
for some reason i kept thinking there
were six issues of the lives and deaths
of wolverine when there's only five so
that's why i took it so long because i
was like where are these six issues at
man come on marvel get it together and
it looks like it was just me so uh in
the last video the last video we did on
the 10 lies of wolverine um what did
essentially happen here what economy
going on behind the scenes is that omega
red was the one who was hopping through
the time stream basically trying to find
a way to destroy charles xavier and that
wolverine's mind had been sent into the
past to basically stop omega red we
didn't fully know exactly how it was
that omega red ended up in the time
stream but we eventually learned that
mikhail rasputin who is what you would
call a reality breaker this guy is he's
great i love mikhail rasputin um that he
had basically used what was called the
cerebro sword which was basically like a
technological sword essentially that
where xavier could use cerebro to take
the mind of wolverine and send it into
the past that using the cerebro sword
and plunging it into the chest of omega
red that mchale could send the mind of
omega red or even his spiritual essence
to a degree into the past which
basically allowed it allowed this kind
of cat and mouse game between arcadia
and logan and so because of that one of
the things that had gone on here is that
ultimately omega red had realized that
with wolverine trying to stop him every
step of the way the best way to to
essentially guarantee the destruction of
uh professor xavier somewhere in the
time stream before he can form the x-men
and all that kind of stuff is to
basically take over wolverine and that's
exactly what omega red did and that's
why you see wolverine kind of thrashing
here as best he can and really xavier
and jean grey doing what they can but
one of the things that they say here is
that with omega red taking over the mind
of logan that because of the fact that
logan's mind was in the time stream that
in essence what omega red had done is he
had just gone to the body of wolverine
and just taken that over right so it's
like if you could remove your essence
from your physical body your physical
body is just a shell it's just sitting
there so all somebody would have to do
is come along and just step into your
body and then they control you and
that's exactly what's happening here and
the biggest concern is that if that's
the case wolverine's mind being lost in
the time stream i mean here's the thing
it's like trying to find a needle in a
stack of needles say for example that
like wolverine's physical body had been
lost somewhere in the time stream well
then they can use some kind of
modification on cerebro they can search
the time stream and then likely pinpoint
where wolverine is right within reason
you know within maybe a day or so or
something like that you know kind of
figure out where he's at and as you guys
know wolverine does go on the move in
those early days he was on the move all
the time but he would he would be on the
move in like a general geographical area
right it wouldn't be one of those things
where like one day he's in in like the
canadian wilderness and the next day
he's in like south america one because
at that point in time it was impossible
to travel between those two places over
the course of a day and two well they
didn't have planes back then but two it
was just one of those things where he
would just reside in a general area for
a while when it comes to his mind being
lost how the hell do you find that i
mean xavier is powerful but we haven't
really seen a whole lot of instances
where his mind can search the entire
time stream and two even in those
instances where he has it takes him a
long time to pinpoint a particular
person plus trying to discern the
difference between the modern day
wolverine's mind being lost in the time
stream versus like any iteration of his
younger self right so it's just it makes
it incredibly difficult to do but
ultimately we do switch over to younger
wolverine in uh in 1900 right now
remember this is about the earliest
version of his character that we saw in
this kind of time fight between himself
and and omega red and of course he ended
up saving this version of uh of charles
and what what ended up you know really
happening following this is that logan
stayed on board as basically uh i don't
know what you would really call it in
the world of like sailing in the world
of ships but like an assistant
i don't i don't i don't know ship terms
right i don't understand ship terms
right if any of you guys do post a
comment i'm sure people would just
they'd be curious just to see what it is
uh but unless wolverine was basically
here or logan was here as essentially an
assistant now a part of me also has to
believe the reason he stayed on board is
to also ensure that like omega red
wouldn't come back and try to kill
basically this version of charles but
also keep in mind that the the modern
day wolverine when his essence goes into
a younger version of himself as soon as
the mission is accomplished he leaves
and so it's almost like modern wolverine
possesses younger wolverine and then
xavier saved so modern wolverine moves
on to another version of himself in the
time stream so in effect this younger
version of logan is really him he's not
possessed by his future self who's
traveling through time and it's really
kind of interesting in terms of why he
stayed here because one of the things
that this version of charles says right
this this you know way back in the day
version of charles like it's great great
great some you know amplified several
times over father uh that he he was like
look man like given everything you've
done and the way you've been in service
to me we could take you back to england
right we could have you basically
brought in as a cadet of the royal navy
which i don't know if that's a big deal
or not but we can make a life for you
right and the the response of this
version of logan is no i have no loyalty
not to a flag not to anybody like i'm
just and so it's kind of cool then why
are you here you know if it's like hey
man like you've been just kind of here
on this job site hanging around for a
little while do you want a job no i
don't want a job i don't have loyalty to
anybody and then you just run off into
the sunset it's like okay i guess that
kind of makes sense um it may also be
because of the fact that you know they
were stranded just sort of out in the in
the arctic right when when logan first
came across him and they've just been
making their way back to canada ever
since and they just got here right and
so he's just like i mean look man you
were way back you know you were my ride
but don't be don't have any illusions
man like just because you know i
hitchhiked and you picked me up does not
mean i want to be your best friend and
then you know ultimately just kind of
ends up leading but before he does what
ends up happening is this this version
of charles gives logan a watch and it's
like look okay i understand you have no
loyalties you don't want to be tied down
to people that's cool do your thing but
take this right i feel i owe you for
saving my life please accept this gift
that i'm giving to you uh what you do
with it is up to you but i feel like at
the very least this is a way in which i
can thank you you know and it's a really
really cool thing because he says like
it's a compass but it's also a watch and
the response to charles is no matter how
deep in the wilderness you travel i hope
you never lose your way so it's kind of
the sentimental really kind of bond
between the two and so following that of
course as younger wolverine is making
his way back to shore he's seized by
xavier in the present day and xavier is
like okay like do not lose your way
here's the thing you have to come back
to us now what charles xavier is doing
here is he's using the mind of the
younger wolverine as an anchor point
right seemingly it's like present-day
wolverine's mind touched the mind of his
younger self so it's like tracing
breadcrumbs right following footsteps or
tracks in the snow and so using that
while he's not able to exactly pinpoint
a modern wolverine it's enough to where
he can kind of reach out to his his
mental imprint out there in the time
stream using his younger self as an
anchor point which is just kind of like
you have to come back like i don't know
where you are but you have to find a way
back to us and that of course leads to
the younger wolverine or at least leads
to wolverine's mind returning to its
physical body and in doing so it forces
the mind of of omega red out of the body
of wolverine so things are back to the
way that they're supposed to be that the
mind of omega red goes back into his own
body wolverine gets his body back and
then it's just like okay so while i was
in the body of omega red like i
basically saw through the eyes of omega
red and i saw what was going on of
course he also saw what was going on
here and so ultimately what you end up
doing is you switch over to russia with
mikhail rasputin and there's actually a
lot more going on here than there
initially seems which is really
interesting and so of course with omega
red basically waking up this is when
mikhail rasputin is like you're an
absolute failure right like you are just
as much of a failure as i thought you
were like literally you had the whole of
the time stream to find a way to kill
charles xavier and you couldn't do it
the whole time stream sure wolverine was
finding you but like you had the
entirety of the time stream you didn't
even have to like attack xavier head on
you could have just like taken over the
body of some assassin you could have
taken over the body of like like uh i
don't i don't know black widow and like
assassinated xavier as he was just going
down the road somewhere but you could
have been you could have been anybody in
the time stream and instead you omega
red are the same idiot you always were
which is well there's xavier i'm going
to attack him head on right and so it's
really interesting because in a lot of
ways what it's doing is it's almost kind
of benjamin percy i wouldn't say poking
fun at his own plot but basically
focusing on the idea that omega red is
just not capable and ultimately omega
red even tries to beg and it's like look
okay fine send me back right like like i
am not giving you the cerebral sword
back send me back like 5 000 years or
something like that and like we'll find
a way to win but the reality here is
that michael rasputin isn't really
talking about the failure of omega red
in the sense that he could not kill
xavier head on again he's talking about
the failure of omega red in the sense
that like he's got no imagination and in
truth that was one of the biggest weak
points of omega red now make no mistake
because of how he was written back in
the day right like back in the 90s and
because the 90s were an era of just high
octane fast-paced stories oh mega red
was brutal he wasn't really as brutal as
characters were in like the 80s like let
me tell you something man comic book
characters in the 80s like look here's
the thing man saber tooth for example in
the 1980s oh he was nuts it was amazing
reading saber two stories back in the
1980s he was just brutal right like like
you go back and you pick up any of those
comics that were written in the 80s
about saber-tooth it's no you'd be like
no way marvel would write a story like
this about sabretooth now now it's all
about sabers who's you know he's he's in
the middle of fighting wolverine but
it's not really the fight like he's not
really like a fight knock down dragon
fight it's like yeah they're they're
skirmishing but back in the 1980s man
there were some brutal fights and the
way that omega red was written in the
90s was much the same way right he was
extreme hardcore and a lot of that's
changed even through all of that the
biggest issue with omega red is he was
never imaginative and that's one of the
things that like mikhail rasputin says
is you know what i should never have
relied on you uh omega red like you know
you keep the damn cerebral sword i don't
care you know i've got places to be i
knew i never should have relied on you
after all you are a relic of the old
soviet russian republic right the old
soviet republic and they had no
imagination they had no real ingenuity
they couldn't think outside the box i
need a new russia but i need a more
ingenuitive mind out there besides your
own and he ultimately ends up leaving
now having said all of that about how
like omega red in the modern day isn't
nearly as brutal as it used to be
benjamin percy picks fixes that in an
instant right so what ends up happening
is of course you basically have uh
wolverine who's teleported to where
omega red is located and what follows is
probably one of the most brutal fights
in the history of these two characters
and keep in mind man again we're
comparing this to like everything from
basically 1992 and 1993 going forward
throughout the 1990s now the reality is
omega red only really had like one and a
half good years in marvel comics
before marvel basically crapped the bed
and uh almost went bankrupt and just
couldn't really tell can store
compelling stories about omega rad
because they were trying to financially
stay afloat but the fights between him
and wolverine were legendary and that's
exactly what you get here but it's one
of those things where where wolverine
has this amazing monologue that he goes
into and i i love this monologue it's
absolutely phenomenal right so as these
two guys are fighting what wolverine
says here is he says something happens
when you live a long time and you travel
a lot you like going back to places he
says you like to seek out on purpose
what you found by accident before to
recapture the feeling of discovery if
you find where you've been before
whether it's a bar in an alley a shrine
on a mountain everything inevitably is
different that mountain's still there
but it's smaller the day is stormy
instead of sunny it's spring instead of
autumn you're alone instead of with pals
whatever but that electricity is still
there you plug it in you remember where
you've been then you remember how far
you've come and that's the mystery of
repetition and he says it opens up more
mysteries even as it brings clarity this
is probably more important to me than
anybody else because my brain's always
been broken i can't properly patch
together everyone i've loved and killed
every decade i endured every army and
team i've been a part of every
organization that's used me every bottle
of whiskey drank and claw popped and
mouth smashed against mine in a savage
kiss it's the mind wipes it's the memory
plants it's the expanse of time it's the
centuries plus of living and fighting
that has taken a toll i've never known
what was real or not i still don't know
despite traveling back the way i came
because i changed the way of things no
point in dedicating too much time or
worry to history you can't change the
story that's already started the only
thing you can control is the ending and
this is just an amazing monologue here
and here's the reason why because
wolverine because of the fights that he
and omega red have had both over the
course of his life and then in terms of
marvel publication history for the short
amount of time that omega red was really
really really relevant that he talks
about familiarity here there is a
familiarity in terms of his fighting
with omega red that it's something he
knows that it's not simply just a time
stream thing that the two of them have
been fighting for any number of years
but in terms of of one of the things and
probably the most interesting thing
about this is yes there's the mind wipes
yes there's the false memory implants
which technically shouldn't be the case
because of the post-decimation era or
the post-house of m era uh in decimation
wolverine getting his memories back
although marvel had changed that
following daniel way's wolverine origins
um that the the idea of wolverine just
having been alive for so long that think
about yourself for example right i know
that for example you have moments in
your life where you look back and you're
like i wonder if that really happened or
if it was just a dream right did i dream
i did that or did i really actually do
that and it all just kind of meshes
together and there are elements of your
life where you're not even sure that
truly happened and that's you at maybe
like 30 years old or 40 years old or 50
or 60 years old now imagine you're 200
years old did you really fall in love
with that woman or did you dream it did
you really have that child or is it just
something you imagine that just feels
real because your mind is trying to find
some way to make sense of this thought
that you're uncertain about right
whatever the case happens to be after a
while the experience of your life it all
just kind of merges together into a
series of scenarios that may or may not
be real leaving out all the mind wipes
and the memory implants right that in
and of itself makes things more
difficult then you add in the false
memories and you add in the mind wipes
and your life literally becomes a
smorgasbord of memories which may or may
not be true and so following this again
this this fight between the two was
absolutely amazing and i absolutely
adored it following basically what looks
like the death of omega red whether or
not it'll stay whether it'll stick or
not i have no idea i mean wolverine
literally ripped him in half it seems as
though omega red may very well be
resurrected back in corcoa but remember
they decide who gets resurrected and who
doesn't and that while omega red had
previously been brought back oh mega red
actively worked to kill xavier
the the the mutants on kakoa really have
no motivation to bring him back so he
may or may not return right it may be
one of those things where they're
essentially putting him on the back
burner and then at some future point in
time benjamin percy's left it open for a
rider to bring him back depending on the
circumstance and whether or not it's
needed but a cool thing about this kind
of a small little takeaway about this is
that you do have this bit of a of a log
book right remember that we get these
log books over the course of the x-men
comics which are designed to kind of
fill things in and then what we get from
the log of sage who again is basically
kind of like the living computer of
cocoa the one that keeps an eye on on
like different transcripts and and audio
feeds and all kinds of stuff that she's
basically been keeping an eye on mikhail
rasputin and that from an anonymous
source which came from the daily bugle
mikhail rasputin failed to fulfill a
promise to russia and now he finds
himself in a situation of defensive
retreat the kremlin is presently in a
closed door session with him shouting
can be heard on both sides what is the
expression in english on his knees
mikhail rasputin is on his knees and so
in effect whatever it was that led to
mikhail rasputin basically grabbing
omega red and then sending him into the
time stream in order to kill xavier that
this is basically him working for the
kremlin working for what is either the
russian government or a basically a
secret faction in the russian government
that was looking to kill charles xavier
and eliminate the entirety of krakowa
retroactively by going back in time so
they're messing with the time stream
again we don't necessarily know who this
is but i am interested in finding out
and so the last little tidbit that we
get here because this cerebro sword is
basically an artifact that can send the
consciousness of a person into the past
so this sword has probably become one of
the most important things in the
entirety of marvel comics right now the
sword is handed over to sage by
wolverine and of course she's like okay
like i'm gonna go sleep for a year she's
like actually you can't uh we need you
and he's like what could you possibly
need right now she's like well the
island's under attack and when one brain
asks okay well it must not be that
massive of a threat because quite
literally uh i don't see the whole
island mobilizing the response of stage
is well it's actually under attack by
you by omega wolverine so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
[Laughter]
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace